you imagine oh wow deeper hello I'm
Megan Perez from Perth Western Australia
and I'm 15 years old
our phone conversations the best so
let's say you would ever have tell me
there to sail across the Sun there to
make it to the Milky Way to see the lad
self fade after school I like listening
to music I like playing guitar and piano
and also just playing songs that I
learned from the internet
how'd you know
I have one older sister and one younger
sister my older sister lives in America
and my younger sister she's still 12 she
lives with us at her my dad is a
maritime surveyor and my mom is in the
transport and logistics field
my dad he surveys ships so he goes to
different ports and sometimes he has to
go away just to survey ships I just like
being impressive on court I like playing
with my friends and using the knee pads
usually I start off as the first set up
which is a person in the middle at the
front since my parents are from the
Philippines it's interesting visiting
the Philippines so often because going
back to the Philippines and driving
around you see smaller children in the
streets the with no clothes and they're
dirty and they're bathing in the rain in
the sewers but they still smile they're
still having a good time and then it
just makes me think about how when I go
home from school and I have a hot shower
it's I take it for granted the backhand
is melting donut diamonds now to me as
we start helping and contributing in
small ways eventually turns out to be
bigger and when more people get involved
I think that's when we can really help
other people
you